While it might seem a little extreme to
put a whole datacenter at the bottom of ocean,
datacenters strike at the core of what this company does, at what Microsoft does.
It is a kind of a far-out idea,
but highly relevant to the future of Microsoft.
And as we look at the world today, we see many more
interactive applications, things like AR and VR.
In order to really address that and provide this more responsive cloud, one of the things we look at
is bringing the cloud closer to our customers.
Project Natick, not only is it exercising green tech,
but it's also an exercise in whether we can get to a mass production concept.
The leadership in offshore renewable energy is really in Europe.
Scotland is also home to the European Marine Energy Centre,
which is the largest test site in the world for offshore renewable energies like tide and wave energy.
Putting something the ocean is something that we don't really have a whole lot of experience with.
For this deployment, we're working with a company called Naval Group of France.
Getting that group of engineers in the same room with our group of engineers,
you know, there were ideas that came up and that spur an idea in someone else,
it really led us to get to the design that we right now.
The vessel was built as two pieces.
There's an external shell which is the pressure
vessel itself and then an internal payload.
So this datacenter runs entirely off renewable energy.
Our vessel is powered by a combination of solar power,
wind power, and offshore tidal and wave energy.
This is a true lights out datacenter.
People have been wanting to design such
a datacenter for the last decades that
I've been involved in the business,
and this is the very first one
that I've actually seen that we're going to do it.
And we'll see what happens.
So we had around 35 people on the sea, five boats.
And on a different crew, we had the team checking
all the electricity to make sure that the
connections were just perfect.
(off-camera dialogue among crew)
The Natick datacenter by no means replaces those big datacenters we have come to know.
Just being able to order precisely the
amount of datacenter capacity you need
and have it delivered to you, that is the product concept that we dream about with Project Natick.